you know there's this idea i think is
malcolm gladwell about how if you spend
like 10 000 hours doing something you
become
like really really expert it sounds like
at this point you've probably put in
about that many hours if you add up like
all the times performing in washington
square park
and then all the time um is that
fair to say i mean your younger brothers
it seems like they started out very
young
as well um you guys must be like
incredibly veteran
um musicians and performers at this
point do you believe in the 10 000 hour
principle or something like it i do
believe in the ten thousand hour
principle but i believe in it for every
bit of it
meaning if you're a writer and you're
writing your own music you need to put
ten thousand
ten thousand hours into writing if
you're just gonna play you need to put
ten thousand hours into playing
if you want to you know figure out the
branding and marketing and the messaging
of something you need to put 10 000
hours into that so
the music industry is so much more than
just making a song and putting it out
there are so many other pieces that go
into it
but yeah i'm a big believer in paying
your dues and putting in your time
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks i'm zach
grauman your co-host
every once in a while and yang speaks we
get a treat and today is a treat andrew
said after he recorded this he's like i
think this is one of the best episodes
we ever did
which is a good pretty good bar so today
adam met from the band ajr
and if you don't know what ajr is you're
old but they're she really really
talented
and adam is just an awesome guy he's got
this fun career
and he is really really devoted to
climate change and very very um
frankly well educated on the topic
particularly for how young he is
so you've got an incredible artist
and someone who's really trying to uh
make the world a better place
talking to andrew um who's always trying
to make the world a better place and you
end up with a very fascinating
conversation about
uh the music industry and also how we
can
fix the planet so don't miss this
episode adam met from ajr
on yank speaks right now
[Music]
it is my distinct pleasure to welcome to
the podcast
world famous musician one of the well
the oldest brother in ajr
uh and uh international environmental
activist adam met welcome to the podcast
adam
andrew i'm so excited to be here great
to see you we are so excited to have you
adam holy cow
man when i met you uh last year i was
like wait a minute this guy's a rock
star getting his phd
in what
some of those things didn't really
compute so i guess we'll we'll dig into
the rockstar
part first and then we'll we'll go
towards what you're working on now
um but even the story of ajr
and for those of you who don't know you
really should just uh you know like
spotify ajr or youtube music ajr
um i had this uh this joke and you saw
it on twitter adam where
i mentioned it to my young staffer uh
um that you and i might speak and then
he was like oh what are they saying and
then we started playing the songs from
ajr and he was like that's them that's
them too
it so behaved like over and over again
so i'd encourage anyone
listening to this it was like like who's
ajr who's adam met just
go ahead and uh have that experience
because you'll find out that
um they they sing half a dozen of the
songs that you've uh
like rocked out to the car
or elsewise getting to that place where
you know
you're a bunch of songs versus a
household name
it's something you know every artist is
trying to figure out how do you become
like
imagine dragons as opposed to three
different songs that
are by imagine dragons so it's something
we're working on right now
well you're somewhere between a bunch of
songs and imagine dragons in my mind
there i mean there's certainly a bulk of
people
for whom you know you are a household
name i'm fascinated by your story
because you grew up here in new york
your parents are architects so it's not
like your showbiz kids and then you and
your two younger brothers just start
making music
and then you make music on the streets
of new york like for whatever reason
this does not compute to
uh to pop star a rock star so can you
talk about your
like when you and your brothers were
just messing around like in the living
room
yeah it actually started with our dad
because our dad was a huge
music fan especially of music from the
60s and 70s so he would play us
vinyl growing up of simon and garfunkel
and the beach boys and even like peter
paul and mary
and we started replicating the harmonies
just around the house that we would hear
on those vinyls and then we said okay
let's
take this out and see what happens if we
go into washington square park because
we grew up right near washington square
park and street performing culture is
such a big thing there i mean
you go out now into the park and you see
puppet shows and people doing flips over
each other and some jazz bands and
it was just part of the normal culture
of growing up in manhattan
let's see if this is a thing let's see
if people will actually stop when
they're on their way to work and
hear us sing and people stopped we had a
hat out and jack my youngest brother he
was
either seven or eight when we first
started okay wait so he's eight now how
old are you during during
this debut uh i was 14 or 15.
okay so you're the older brother and
then uh and then there's a younger
brother who's like eight then there's a
middle brother who's maybe like 11 at
this time or
like what what's that yeah 11 or 12. yep
all right so my natural instinct is that
you must have been the ringleader
because
i have an older brother and he was
definitely the person who did stuff
first and then after he did it i
followed so
were you the person who was like hey
guys you want to go out to the park
[Laughter]
i mean i i wish i could claim you know
the leadership role
but funny enough it was all three of us
like all three of us had really specific
kind of different interests in music
and uh it all kind of came together into
this thing where we
all have our own roles that have
continued to now um and
i guess it was me who said you know you
take this and you take this and we'll
carry it out to the park kind of thing
but in terms of the interest in actually
doing the music
it really was equal i didn't have to
force them to do it at all
well it certainly seems like you all
have a very deep innate
interest in music uh so you go out there
you have a few instruments like you you
were
on guitar and singing i think and then
your brothers were
had other instruments and so what kind
of feedback does one get
and then do you measure your success
based on frankly how much money people
put in the hat
[Laughter]
and and what do your parents think about
this at the time
do are they cool with the three of you
just being out in the park um
doing this like do they feel any need to
chaperone you
like is there anything there so the
second part of the question our parents
chaperoned
just about every time and some of some
of the time we did it you know not
following the rules exactly because
technically you're supposed to have a
license when you have amplified music
and some of the times we didn't actually
have the license we were supposed to
um so you know our mom came by and
and she you know talked to the police
officers and the police officers were
you know you're supposed to have a
license and she would go
oh no he's eight years old he didn't
know they're supposed to be a license
so she kind of took on that role and
then eventually we started having a
license every time we did it but
measuring success that that's a really
good question because
in the moment we measured the success in
terms of how much money we would get and
once in a while somebody with their like
a 20 in the hat and we would be so
excited
sometimes people threw rocks in the hat
and that was not very exciting
sometimes people tried to steal the
microphones from us and that was not
exciting
but i guess you know retrospectively
the success from that time was learning
how to perform in front of an audience
that didn't care about you at all
because that's what you get in street
perform you have to convince people that
don't want you to be there to stop and
take a moment
and listen and give you money so now
we don't get nervous at all when we go
on stage now because that was the most
nervous you could possibly be
you know putting out this janky little
speaker that doesn't really work well
trying to convince people to stop and
listen to you sing
and we also tap danced at that time in
order to try and get people's attention
wait does that mean you had a little um
a little floor
and tap shoes in order to make the
sounds oh yes yep we had a little wooden
board that we would put out and
all three of us tap dance in in a
previous life
i i taught tap dance for for quite a
while in new york
wow so that means you still must
have some very fancy footwork right i
mean if anyone did that at any point in
their life they could still probably do
some things
we may or may not be including a little
bit of it
the next time we go on tour wow well
another reason to go check out ajr
in tour which i think i was gonna come
to this a little bit later but we might
as well discuss
it since you brought it up are you guys
on tour right now
let's go ahead and i wanted to ask about
this in part because frankly it's like
post pandemic
rock concerts are back what does that
look like what does the industry look
like
the industry is a little bit rough right
now we played our
first show about a week ago in
uh was the first show in about a year
and a half um
and it was it was a really good show
and if this was a year and a half ago it
would have been a fine show
but the fact that it was the first one
back it actually felt really amazing to
play in front of an audience and it was
it was a college show that we did down
in annapolis
and it was the first one back and the
next one we have isn't until july
so when you ask if we're on tour again
we have a bunch of one-off shows we have
some festivals that we're playing this
summer
but to me touring is getting in a tour
bus waking up in a different city
every day like loading into an
amphitheater or an arena
and you know playing for five to ten
thousand of our own fans and
unfortunately that's not really gonna
happen until
next year april of next year because we
wanted to to make sure that
every single person could come to our
shows meaning you know kids
all the way through grandparents because
we have such a wide range of people that
come to the show
and we want to make sure every single
person can get the vaccine before before
we start touring again
so let's talk about this one show you
did where you say it's a good show and
it would have been a good show like
18 months ago like what what was the
venue what was the capacity like it
sounds like it was a college show so it
was uh you know like college students
like yeah
what does that look like it was at the
u.s navy academy
in annapolis maryland so it was a
completely locked down campus we needed
to get
you know covid tests before we went in
and everyone was wearing masks in the
audience and when we got there
we thought everyone was going to be
seated and all six feet apart in these
chairs and there was going to be no
energy in the crowd
but because everyone had to get negative
tests or have a vaccine
it was a mosh pit the entire time it was
probably
i don't know two to three thousand
cadets they're called midshipmen which i
learned
they'd probably be pretty fired up yeah
if you were like a two to three thousand
cadets at one of like the first
uh you know live concerts
over here yeah yeah and it was just
a party and the crazy thing is our song
bang which got really big last year
we never got to play it live in front of
an audience this was the very first time
and it was you know a top 10 song on the
billboard 100 so a lot of people knew it
and we couldn't really measure if people
knew it or it just you know
looked like people knew it based on the
numbers so the fact that they were
singing the song back to us and this was
the first time we heard it it was
it was quite a moment
[Music]
[Applause]
all right want to talk to you guys about
better help which is our sponsor on yang
speaks
i think most people lost their mind
during covid i personally did
and one of my i call it my steam valve
is my better help time once a week so i
meet with my counselor
basically just helps me blow off steam
in a really healthy way i just talk
about things i never talk about and it's
great
and it's needed right now just say hey
what the heck is happening in the world
and talk about what we're all going
through what you personally are going
through whether it's depression
stress anxiety relationships sleeping
trauma anger
grief self-esteem you name it for me
it's helping focus my ambition
and understand how i react to certain
things in the world
it's awesome i love it i look forward to
it every week so here's the deal
i want you to start living a happier
life today i want you to check out
better help and as a listener you're
going to get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor at betterhelp.com
yang join over 1 million people have
taken charge of their mental health
again that's betterhelp help dot com
slash yang
[Applause]
so let's return to the you and your
young brother is playing in front of
people that
don't care about you in in new york
and i think a lot of people in new york
can relate to that like you know because
you walk around there people performing
and it's not like you like stop it and
i'm like huh
like what's going on here like you know
a lot of times just walking by
i'm going to share a story where i feel
like i can relate to that because i ran
for president
i did oh yeah yeah i did so there
and there was like an extended period
let's call it 2018
when i was running for president and no
one cared
and so you would go and that there would
be
these uh different types of venues so
like if i were to speak in front of like
a group of sort of curious
uh friends of friends or whatnot um then
that was one dynamic
uh we had our own mini tour
which uh drew a certain number of people
that was a different dynamic but the
dynamic that
reminded me of what you described was
that i would speak in these political
gatherings
in iowa and new hampshire
where they had democratic clubs
who would bring various candidates in
and
people did not care about andrew yang
uh sort of novelty presidential
candidate
in those venues you know i was there
typically as part of a program
there might be a few other speakers
let's call them jeff merkley and
uh tulsi gabbard and maybe jay inslee or
people like that so i'd be like the
least
uh attractive show that we say
like of of these speakers where it's
like andrew yang what like entrepreneur
what
um and so there was a lot of talking to
people who did not care
uh and uh there was like some
um strengthening to that um you're right
where later when people did care you
were like oh wow
like this is like this is better that is
interesting
but you kind of get used to people not
caring and it does toughen you up
yeah i feel like that the parallels
there are so strong because
even when we were performing on the
street we didn't have a twitter
we didn't have an instagram it was just
in the moment for people to
hear what we were saying and then when
we started going on tour our first
show ever was in new jersey and three
people showed up
literally three people sure three people
man the dude one person showed up to my
first
event in new hampshire it's like coffee
with
the candidate it was like one person i
just ended up
like you know talking to other people in
the cafe who had no idea who i was
um so when was this first show of yours
like uh
how old were you we're gonna use your
age as the chronology so you're like
start out in the park
at at 14 or 15. how old were you when
this first show happened
i was born in 90 so in 2012
you're 22 22. when you're 18
you go to college at columbia which
happens to be my alma mater
uh mom and my wife's alma mater actually
um
so very handy that you go to columbia
because that means you can still hang
out and play music with your brothers
um though i will say that frankly i'm
just gonna lay this out for you adam
if you're a college guy it sounds pretty
lame to be going
home to play music with your brothers
when there's all of that college stuff
going on and socializing so what the
heck does that look like
that's a great question um
i was i was a lame nerd i was a lame
nerd and i am i was that's a good answer
good answer adam good answer i'm proud
of it now so
it ended up working out in the long run
so oh yeah it really do that
for sure um so tell us about your your
college schedules you're in classes
columbia's pretty rigorous um so did you
uh go home
did first i mean you did you might have
even lived at home i guess there's a
possibility because that would have been
a money saver
there was one semester where i did end
up living at home but the rest of the
time i lived on campus
and my middle brother ryan for my
last semester at school that was his
first semester so he overlapped
and that was the semester that hurricane
sandy happened
and the funny story about that is um
our home down in chelsea where we grew
up lost power during hurricane sandy
so he came over to my dorm room from his
dorm room up at columbia
because colombia still had power because
you know it's a little bit higher than
than chelsea and during hurricane sandy
we recorded the vocals for our first
song that became a platinum record which
was a song called i'm ready
and that was done in harmony hall on
110th street
in my dorm room in the middle of
hurricane sandy
and that's what kicked everything off
wow i'll tell you i've got a hurricane
sandy story too which is that my
uh oldest son was born during hurricane
sandy
um so we remembered very well he was a
bit early because when the pressure
changes apparently all babies want to
be born so what a big what a big night
that was
sandy like you make your first platinum
record i become a dad
um so how did your music look during
the the first few years of your being in
college before your brother shows up
our music during that time was terrible
because when we were in the park we were
mostly doing covers of other people but
when
i was in college we experimented with a
lot of different genres so that's music
that is
never gonna see the light of day we have
all of that in our you know on our hard
drives but
we would spend you know six months
working on song that was music that
sounded very musical theater and then we
would spend
six months working on music that was
very hip-hop focused and ryan my middle
brother wrapped on a couple of songs and
those will
definitely never come out um but then we
did some songs that were more like
simon and garfunkel folk and it took all
of that time
over those four years to say okay we
want to bring a little bit of this genre
in a little bit of this genre a little
bit of this genre
until we actually found our sound and
that's one of the things when when
other newer artists are asking us for
advice we say
take the time to explore what you want
your sound to be
because if you write a song and then put
out your first song if that's not what
you want to be
you're you're throwing something out
there that you've now established
yourself this is the sound that you have
so take some time to really figure out
who you want to be
as an artist and that's what we did when
i was in college so i would go home
and we would play and we would write and
we would record things and like i said
most of it is terrible and most of it's
going to be terrible in the beginning
because you're just learning how to do
it
but we took that time to figure out okay
this is what ajr sound is this is what
we want to communicate with our lyrics
and then when we started putting stuff
out for real then we had a concrete idea
of okay this is the path we want to go
down
so how many hours a week would you go
play or make music with your
brothers when you were in college maybe
10 to 12 hours a week
um i would go home and i would always
you know combine it with bringing
laundry home for my parents to do my
laundry when i would
you know go do that or make them make me
dinner or something like that
so then my next question is about your
brother applying to college because he
ends up getting into colombia
it sounds like as during your final
semester at columbia and his first
semester at columbia
then your younger brothers in in high
school that you make your first hit
and it probably takes a bit of time for
it to become a hit but you know what is
the process you write this song
and then how does it get out into the
world and what happens next
so we wrote this song in the fall of
2012
and this was the the either the end of
the
our career or the beginning of our
career and i'll explain what i mean by
that
we decided that we had written so many
songs and we had you know
tested them out on youtube and
soundcloud and places like that
and we decided okay if this one doesn't
do anything
then we're just gonna pause we're really
just gonna focus on school and get a
real job
what sorry wow this is very very high
stakes here adam
um but well before we see we before we
we get to that um you know there's this
idea i think is malcolm gladwell about
how if you spend like 10
000 hours doing something you become
like really really expert
it sounds like at this point you've
probably put in about that many hours if
you add up like all the times performing
in washington square park and then all
the time
is that fair to say i mean your younger
brothers it seems like they started out
very young as well
you guys must be like incredibly veteran
musicians and performers at this point
do you believe in the ten thousand hour
principle or something like it i do
believe in the ten thousand hour
principle but i believe in it for every
bit of it
meaning if you're a writer and you're
writing your own music you need to put
ten thousand ten thousand hours into
writing
if you're just gonna play you need to
put ten thousand hours into playing
if you wanna you know figure out the
branding and marketing and the messaging
of something you need to put ten
thousand hours into that so
the music industry and i'm sure we can
talk about this more but it's so much
more than just
making a song and putting it out there
are so many other pieces that go into it
but yeah i'm a big believer in paying
your dues and putting in your time
okay so back to 2012 you have this uh
hit song and you're like okay guys if
this thing doesn't work out maybe we
should
go become management consultants or
something
[Laughter]
i mean i made that up but um so so what
is the process through which this
music gets out in the world so
it all happened during a psychology
class at columbia
so i'm sitting paying attention taking
notes and ryan is sitting next to me
on twitter and he's taking the link on
youtube of this the song i'm ready that
we put out
and he's tweeting it out to you know 100
different celebrities from miley cyrus
to justin bieber
and the very last one we did where he
did was sia
and sia was the only one who responded
and said
i love this she retweeted it and she
said come downtown and meet me at my
hotel
i want to meet you guys and we thought
we thought she was catfishing us we
thought it was like a fake account
this was before the point when she was
wearing the the um you know the bag
over her head and before she had the wig
so we went down to her hotel
and she walks literally out of her hotel
singing our song and said
okay let's go to brunch and we went to
brunch with sia and that was kind of the
the very beginning of it she introduced
us to people in the industry
we met with a few labels i love sia so
much now
this is the greatest story of all time
she's she's amazing because not only is
she an amazing artist
she's an amazing writer and she can get
in the mindset of so many different
artists and write songs based on their
perspective and that's one of the things
that we really appreciated about her
this seems like a movie plot it seems
like uh you know like
the end of a disney movie um you know
where
um sia comes out and connects with
people okay so so
let's go through some of the next things
where so then sia introduces you to
people that are labeled yeah people at
her label people at other labels and we
have a whole bunch of label meetings
and every single one of them said you
know
this song is good but we're going to put
you in the room with really big writers
like max martin and dr luke
and they're going to write all your
songs for you and then you'll put them
out and we said
no we're definitely uninterested in that
and then we met
our manager who she also introduced us
to
and his name is steve greenberg and he
said
i really like what you have because it
doesn't sound like anything else on the
radio
and you said it was it was something
that was unique because we made the
entire record
in that dorm room we in our mix between
our parents living room and that dorm
room
it didn't sound professional it didn't
sound like it was made in a recording
studio
and he said that's what made it stand
out and so
we ended up staying independent and not
doing a record deal
we did a deal with him and started our
own company called ajr
productions that sounds like such a risk
man like i feel like any artist and you
show up
and they're like okay we're gonna do
this thing and here's some producers and
here's some writers and we can work with
this
and then you were like no
that seems incredibly ballsy
it was so risky and basically it was
choosing between do we believe in
ourselves and the vision that we have
for this
or do we want to take the big check
right now but have to completely change
everything about us
there's something really important about
that story adam um because i feel like
the vast majority of humans in that
situation would have been like well
these are professionals they know better
than us
like you know like they know how to make
hits they've got a bunch of platinum
records on the wall we don't have [ __ ]
like that
like you know like like let's get in
there and like see what we can do
together like that
like what percentage of artists do you
think would have had that attitude i
feel like
you know 85 percent would have gone that
direction
i think um were you getting advice from
other people during this time i guess
your parents were like you do you or
like
but like was there were there musicians
we didn't know anybody
the only person we knew that was like
actually in the music industry was sia
at that point and we'd known her for
like a week so we didn't have anybody
giving us advice
and we just said look you know we've
taken skills that we've gotten from
learning music but then we've also taken
skills from i studied business at
columbia so i was like
okay let me think through this from a
business perspective do we want to give
up
all our rights to everything for this
check that could end up being really
small in the long run
or do we want to try because cia really
liked the song let's see if other people
really like the song like
radio stations and it ended up paying
off
oh wait okay so you turn down this this
label deal
but you hook up with sia's manager um
sia introduced us to our current manager
it wasn't her manager
but it was this guy she knew and her
manager knew because he did
hansen and he did the jonas brothers
there is something about like the the
three brothers
uh band i mean i can't believe he did
hansen and the jonas brothers holy [ __ ]
he like specializes in like freaking
brother bands i wonder if he
he just does brother bands you'd be like
if there aren't three brothers i'm not
interested
no the other the songs that you that you
would know that he uh he
did who let the dogs out and it's
actually his voice on the record that's
the dog barking
um he did stacy's mom stacy's mom a huge
you know hit he's done a lot of course
weird songs
so he becomes your manager and then
you're like we're gonna go off on our
own so then what
then our manager sits down and plays our
song called i'm ready for
a guy named kid kelly and kid kelly was
the
you know head of siriusxm hits one which
is
the biggest pop station in the country
on on satellite radio
and he fell in love with it and so
immediately he started playing the song
even before the song officially came out
on itunes which was
crazy then when the song came out on
itunes and this was
pre-streaming being the majority of what
happens in the music industry
he started playing the song on siriusxm
and it just exploded it was doing you
know up to 50 000 copies a week
on itunes which is a lot for for itunes
if you do 50
000 copies a week i think it was 99
cents so it's called 50
of which the artist sees how much yeah
it's a good question so
at that point we had done a partnership
distribution deal
with warner brothers records so we
retained all the rights to everything
and we contracted them to work it to
radio after
siriusxm had so much success and so it
was only worth going to
somebody like warner brothers after we
had proof that the song was
going to do well so siriusxm was our
test case then we brought it to warner
and said
look the song is doing well and so they
worked it to radio but it was still
underneath our own label ajr productions
but to answer your question
it was a joint venture with them so any
profits
off of that one specific song were split
50 50.
and so how much of the let's call it 99
cents
like uh went to you and your brothers so
of the 99 cents
um distribution costs let's call it a
dollar for easier math
distribution cost let's say it's about
20 cents um
for the cost of distributing the record
so we're down to 80 cents
um since it doesn't cost that much to
actually
you know put a song out half of that
would go to warner
and half of that would go to us so we're
at 40 cents at that point
um our lawyers take a piece of it our
business managers take a piece of it our
manager take up
takes a piece of it so at that point
we're probably
down to somewhere around
25 cents for the three of us to split
[Music]
this episode of yang speaks is brought
to you by athletic
greens i freaking love this stuff i
literally just took some
athletic greens it's this wonderful
magical green powder you can get a big
like
container of it or you can get a little
mini pouches for traveling and you scoop
it or you open the pouch put it in some
water mix it up
drink it it tastes great one tasty scoop
of athletic greens contains 75 vitamins
minerals whole food source ingredients
including a multivitamin
multi-mineral probiotic green superfood
blend and more
they all work together to fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet and give
you a little energy which i love and
focus
um and also aids with digestion and
supports a healthy immune system
all without the need to take multiple
vitamins and crap like that so it's very
cool very efficient and very tasty
and plus right now our audience is
getting a free one-year supply of
vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase
so here's the deal visit
athleticgreens.com
yang so join health experts athletes and
health conscious go-getters around the
world
who are making a daily commitment to
getting their health better
every day so again simply visit
athleticgreens.com
yang get your free year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs a
day
do it
[Applause]
so you have this this hit on
siriusxm and on itunes
um did you have an entire album at that
point or like you had this one hit song
or yeah what comes next
it was one song and the song
came and went and we didn't have enough
material to put out an album
so the song you know it died it was it
did well and then
it died and then eight months later we
put out an album
and by all measures the album was not a
success
it was this is so interesting
yeah i i mean we no tv shows invited us
to perform any of the singles from the
album
um when the album came out and we ended
up getting
out of the deal with warner because we
said look if you're not going to work
another single to radio
let us go and we're going to do you know
our own thing and
wow they were actually really nice about
it and that never happens
you know labels will buy up a contract
and they'll shelve somebody that's not
that's not working
but they were gracious enough to let us
go
and then we decided to continue writing
and continue putting out music
until we found that next song that was
really starting to connect
interesting so at this point you're a
college graduate are you back at home
like your brother is uh an undergraduate
your younger brother's in high school i
guess
so like you guys are you're at home and
um
you know and then you're like all right
guys let's make an album let's make
another hit song we proved we can do it
once like now we got some stuff to work
with
that was that was exactly the mentality
you know we've built this fan base oh
in during that time we tried to go on
tour and
having one hit song that goes platinum
does not mean that you can vote
not at all like we played albany for
example 12 people showed up
literally 12 people showed up to the
venue off of a song that was
everywhere and sold you know or had a
million downloads
um so we said you know let's figure out
how do we change the writing style of
our music to make it so that
when people hear the song they'll want
to see who's singing the song
because that didn't happen with our
first song our first song was more of
you know
a big generic party song and we wanted
the next one that got big to be
something a little bit deeper that
people cared about who
we were who the artist was that was
singing it and that was the approach we
took
with the next few songs and the first
song we did of that
um of that arrow was a song called i'm
not famous
i'm not famous was recognizing like
we're nobody we can walk down on the
down the street and no one's gonna know
who we are
even though we had a platinum record and
that's that's just
it is what it is and those kind of
more slightly more complex but also
connectable lyrics
are the things that really started to
grow our fan base our social media
and then the song week came out go ahead
and sing a couple bars from
a week so that someone can because
everyone's heard this song go ahead
but i'm weak and what's wrong with that
boy oh boy i love it when i fall for
that
i'm weak oh
yeah you can sing that part i'm not
saying that no no
i mean i did a bad job of it so um so
so week comes out uh how long is it
between i'm ready and weak coming out
and was weak like the next
major tent pole yeah that was the next
major temple and it was
at least a year and a half if not two
years
between so you're in the lab for like
you know 16 months or whatnot
in those few years the entire industry
shifted
i know i i mean i remember paying 99
cents for itunes songs i liked and then
all of a sudden that that went away
so yeah what's the new model yeah the
new model was
streaming and spotify connected to week
so hard that it was on every single
playlist we were the cover
of you know most of their playlists and
i think now it has over
500 million streams on spotify alone all
right man so let's do some back of the
envelope [ __ ] again
so so like so let's say
andrew yang comes up with some really
like catchy ditty and then i put it on
spotify
and it gets like a million streams
like how much money do i realize because
my sense of things is that i get like a
minuscule amount of money per stream and
then you have to get into like some
crazy number in order for it to
you're gonna get around four tenths of a
cent
per stream i i will actually share a
story
and like as a media um you know i'll
share
my experience um with something called
writing a book
it's like the way i can relate to
aspects of this
so um so it was in 2012
i was named one of fast companies 100
most creative people in business which
at the time was like you know
like like very very awesome uh and then
from that
uh literary agent named uh bird lavelle
uh reached out to me uh took me out to
lunch and said hey you should write a
book
and uh bird lavell is like a really
handsome well-dressed guy he's like the
kind of guy
like you know smiling positive um
and so like having a litter agent like
take you out to lunch and say write a
book you're like wow like i feel so
special
and birds are like generally a great guy
we're friends this day um
but then at the time i was like yeah
write a book like seems hard like i
don't think
i was running a nonprofit at the time um
uh and
i was like i don't know if it's really
going to drive value for the non-profit
um in the way that i'd hope
and then um but then like i decided to
explore it
uh with bird when i realized it was like
well maybe it would drive the nonprofit
um and so with bird's help in a big way
you know we write a proposal shop it to
some
publishers and then harpercollins ends
up i got a few offers but the most
serious one was from harpercollins
and so harpercollins did something close
to what that record label did where it's
like here's an advance here's some
amount of money
write the book and then uh the amount of
money i got per copy of the book
uh was like a buck 50 for a book that uh
you know retailed for
i don't know like 25 26 um
and the and the buck 50 i was getting
like goes against the advance um
so uh i i was paid um you know what felt
like a lot of money at the time
because i was like well i'm like you
know first-time author like the fact
that they were willing to pay me
55 000 to write a book was like great
uh you know and then like the book excel
and then people like oh i make a lot of
money in that book would be like
actually like you know i haven't made
anything because
after the advance because you know you'd
have to sell through a lot of copies in
order to
for uh to get through the advance and
you know my agent who deserved every
penny you know like got a cut of
that 55 000 and so you know i made like
a bit of money
um which i was again very grateful for
um so
so there so that was my experience with
like kind of the unit
uh marginal revenue for the creator
um for doing something that some people
would consider very significant which is
like you know write a book which
it's only quite time consuming in the
rest of it honestly we
wished we'd written music a few decades
ago because when a song was a hit
people had to buy the entire album in
order to get the ones
who have done that adam i'll have you
know i bought cassingles
for all sorts of songs i went out there
and i bought that wamka single
anyway the
the success of one song does not a
millionaire make
even close um and so we started kind of
moving into other areas of the music
industry and we really started to
develop our touring base
um because that song week
was the song that people said i really
like the song
but i want to know who the artist is
that's singing it and so we put a tour
on sale
and you know in each city three to five
hundred people
came out and we did you know the 30
major cities in the u.s
and that those three to 500 people were
our
first like core fan base and
we we keep the same mentality now when
we're putting together a show
but even then when we had a zero dollar
budget for touring and we were in you
know a minivan we said
how do we make a show that's unlike
anything else that's out there
in the in in music and how do we make a
show that'll make
all 300 of those people tell two friends
so next time it'll be you know 900.
wow so awesome
so you go on the tour you see in the
entire country then
uh you know with your brothers you guys
must get along really well because like
being in a freaking tour van
you know for weeks on end i've done
versions of that
and you really have to love each other
like even if you love each other you
hate each other sometimes because you're
just like oh man like
that's super irritating
the rest of it yeah we grew up in a tiny
apartment in new york city the three of
us
shared a room for i mean until i went to
college and we had
three bunk beds it was a lower bed an
upper bed
across to another bed and then a desk
below so we
were forced to get along our parents
just made us get along so
i guess there are benefits to you know
living in a tiny space
well you guys clearly do get along which
is great it's one thing i love about the
brother band thing is because you know
with the normal band like people break
up sometimes you know it's hard to like
like not let egos get in the way and all
that but brothers it's like well can't
break up with your brother
[Laughter]
so your brother is unlike you have to
drop out of college to do this thing are
your parents like
uh hesitant on that level i mean you
know you guys were moderately successful
but it's still
a kind of a big deal yep yeah they
really did not want my brothers to stop
going to school
really didn't and honestly after we did
that tour
that week was attached to they wanted to
go back to school too
so after ryan did ryan had done one
semester
jack was applying to colombia
a couple years later and then after we
went on that tour
jack did his first semester at columbia
and ryan went back and did another
semester at columbia
not because they really cared about the
school itself
but they wanted to be inspired for
writing more music
so they took courses and things that
were just
interesting to them so ryan took like an
evolutionary biology class
you know just because he cared about
that subject not that he would major in
it or anything so
so guys if you hear some weird song
about evolutionary biology from ajr you
know where it came from
they got a lot of inspiration from
observing their friends
going to parties saying okay what do
these kids care about what do people in
college care about when
and that what do these kids care about
like an they got the notebook
a lot of it was about you know
i'm in college am i a kid am i an adult
in what context am i still a kid in one
context
am i an adult how do i relate to other
people around me what am i going to do
when school is over
those kinds of themes tell us about like
the next number of years
and even i'm going to to ask you about
like the new album
because you guys came up with a new
album quite recently
the process of writing our
last few albums and this newest one has
been
what is this going to look like when we
perform it on stage
because after growing our fan base to a
size where we were playing for you know
a few thousand people in each venue
that was the thing that we loved doing
the most you know
hearing people sing the words back to us
meeting people saying oh
this song did this for me or this song
changed my life
that's that's why we do it we want to
express things that that we've gone
through in our lives
and hopefully it's both specific and
general enough that other people will
relate to it
and that energy of being in a crowd is
why we do what we do so it's always been
about let's create the music
but at the same time let's think about
how it's going to translate
to the live stage and this newest album
okay orchestra
was was really tough because the whole
thing was written
during a global pandemic yeah so
when when are we gonna go on tour and we
waited to put it out until we knew when
we were actually gonna go on tour
and we announced the tour and we put the
tour on sale
and in the first weekend alone more
people bought tickets
for that tour than our entire previous
tour
over the course of the in the entire
tour congratulations man
everyone loves you more people have
discovered you like that there's been
like a lot of pent-up um demand
uh that that's amazing you know i love
what you just said
um because it clearly defines a
hierarchy of experience
um and so you have like hey you've got
the your your song and video on youtube
when you perform it on tv is like one
level but you're like no i really want
people to come
uh to the concert to experience them
live and oh by the way
i love performing our songs live about
like a thousand times more than
uh the other things that were that we do
i'm going to compare this once again to
running for president
in a particular way which is uh at the
height of
the campaign we would have rallies of
thousands of people
and there was so much energy there was
nothing like it you'd go out there and
there'd just be like thousands of people
that were fired up about in our case
universal basic income and humanizing
the economy and like a different form of
politics and whatnot
and there was it was incredible
incredible
um my favorite part of the campaign bar
none for sure
was like was doing those kinds of events
um
certainly in our case like it wasn't the
same where it's like it wasn't
that somehow our campaign was like you
know
like experience the campaign live like
it wasn't like that it was like we're
just trying to get
like trying to get votes but
but it's something i can completely
relate to that there is no
experience like connecting to an
audience live particularly if you know
that your work is important to them
definitely and we still do you know
meet and greets and other things to
connect with fans
and even during the the pandemic we did
as many
digital performances as we possibly
could we did a drive-in show
last august where people came with their
cars we performed you couldn't hear
anything out of the speakers
but the music was sent through a
specific uh radio frequency
yeah and you know anything to give
people that sense of
connection or live experience during a
time when you know we were all cut off
from each other
so you have this tour coming up you've
also
become an environmental activist and
you're pursuing your
doctorate which seems which impressed me
a lot um and we were joking about your
dissertation
um and that uh you were joking that you
know when you finish your
dissertation maybe you'll like cut your
hair do something very dramatic so
so what so what is your dissertation in
and by by the way like uh my
brother's uh an academic like the
dissertation really does seem like a
major major life event
milestone like if you get that thing
done it's like oh like this entire like
weight lifts and the rest of it because
it's the first time you have to produce
some substantial original academic
research that's like you know
like like at a level where people are
like this actually is new
this is like a real contribution so
uh so yeah tell tell us about what
you're working on
um intellectually and academically in
your activism
yeah so i am writing my dissertation
on the relationship between human rights
law
and sustainable development and that wow
it it sounds crazy that you know
everything we just talked about for the
last i don't know how long it's been
was all music related but then this is
something that i spend
a lot of my time working on and to to
kind of get into a little more detail
about it if you think about it this way
there are development projects along
around the world that are specifically
focused on
clean energy and they're amazing there
are wind farms solar farms hydroelectric
plants and they're great
but at their core they're still
capitalist enterprises and there are a
lot of multinational corporations that
are providing this great clean
electricity to millions of people
but still removing indigenous
populations from their land
contaminating water and food supplies
and inhibiting their cultural practices
so my my whole kind of
pitch is that as we are moving in this
sustainable direction
we need to ensure that we're binding
human rights obligations
to this future that we're creating we
need to make sure that we're protecting
the human side of what we're doing
in addition to protecting the planet
because now
we have the ability to rewrite the rules
from scratch if we're starting from from
zero and saying okay we're going to move
our entire world to renewable energy
resources
let's say at this time as we're going in
that direction
to ensure that humans are really being
protected
from the ground up well there's nothing
more fundamental as a human right than
having clean air clean water
like a decent environment and and the
rest of it um
so i love the fact that you're trying to
tie together human rights law
uh and sustainable development uh it
makes perfect sense though i can
see why right now they're not tied
together um
so this this work of yours is awesome
and you have
a podcast uh and other resources that
are dedicated to this right
yeah yeah so this started about
i don't know two or three years ago
because i was studying this
and i had the platform of music the un
reached out specifically the un
development program
and they said will you come on board and
help us to amplify our messaging
around sustainability and i said sure
and so you know we did some radio
campaigns and some tv events
and they said okay let's formalize this
relationship so i founded a non-profit
called sustainable partners inc and what
it does
is it it kind of creates bridges between
areas that are have been separate in the
sustainability space so for example
academia has traditionally been very
separate
from the advocacy and activism world so
what we do is we have a fellowship
program that brings together
academics and activists and encourages
them to work together
so we develop high level research but at
the same time
turn it into consumable content and
actionable
actionable work for for people to take
you mentioned the podcast it's called
planet reimagined and for everybody who
subscribes
we plant a tree so we try and take those
little incentives
and build them into everything that
we're doing
academics plus activists sounds awesome
i mean there's so many talented
academics that no one frankly knows
about it
or that work you know because academics
are generally very very nerdy and wonky
and
uh you know like they write something
that's going to get read by like 80
people
and you know i mean no offense because
again my brother is an academic and
actually it's kind of my family's
business like my father
is now a retired professor after being
in industry
my uncle's a professor my grandfather
was a professor
so uh you know it's like so i get it i
mean i love that stuff but like
connecting them to activists
is um is really uh potentially powerful
that that's great
you know the academic world has this
allegiance to tradition
that is hard to overcome and you know
it's these boards of trustees and these
investors it is a very very high bound
industry like it's it's not great that
way but you know honestly there are a
lot of
amazing young people who have come up
with really creative ways to communicate
about environmentalism and
you know tick tock and instagram have
become great ways to
educate yourself albeit at a relatively
surface level not what you're going to
get in academia
but if there was a bridging of those two
spaces i mean think think about the the
vaccine
at the very beginning nobody really
understood what this vaccine was nobody
really understood what mrna was
if there was this bridging between
academia and
young communicators and activists that
could make people aware
this is what it is this is what you want
to put in your body and get this vaccine
we would have i think had a lot more
people adopting sooner and even now a
lot more people
much more willing to get the vaccine so
there's that that missing link between
the high-level science and then the
people who are able to communicate it
well let's work on that man let's get
more people vaccinated 100
so you've got an upcoming tour
sustainable partners the planet
reimagined podcasts you've got a lot
going on
what is the thing uh coming up that
you're most excited about
i can't wait to get my phd done i am in
footnote and citation mode now i just
wow
can't wait that for that look at you man
it's around the corner then if you're in
footnote in citation mode
well adam it's such a pleasure
connecting with you i learned a ton
um i liked you before this convo but i
find you to be an even more
uh inspirational pillar now than before
you're a world-class creative
uh you're on your way to being a
world-class activist
um really man congratulations and let's
let's catch him on tour
uh that i haven't actually seen them
live yet i'm going to change that soon
we'll make that happen i'll make sure to
send you tickets
[Music]
you